[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
6h du matin piscine de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye est déjà quelques
courageux dans l'eau
[Musique]
parmi eux Olivier de Robillard à 53 ans
le saint-germain-nois se prépare au
mondiaux de natation qui se dérouleront
au Japon dans quelques semaines au
programme une heure d'entraînement avec
son coach le nageur kaaris miati
les 50 sont départs une minute donc on a
pas beaucoup de temps de repos et le but
c'est d'essayer d'avoir le même temps à
chaque fois c'est parti pour le 50m nage
libre et après de longues années loin
des bassins le nageur a conservé le goût
de l'effort c'est dur sur le moment mais
après on est bien
pour Olivier reprendre la natation est
apparue comme une évidence natation sera
toujours fait partie de ma vie j'ai
commencé à nager très très jeune j'ai un
peu laissé tomber et j'ai découvert par
hasard il y a 5 ans que les masters
c'était pas fait que pour de la nage
loisirs mes clients aussi des
compétitions d'organiser et c'était pour
moi le déclic pour pour reprendre et un
jour je suis rentré à la maison et j'ai
annoncé à la famille qu'est-ce qui
penserait de que leur papa
participent au championnats du monde de
natation au Japon ça serait l'occasion
de faire un beau voyage avec un
événement plutôt sympathique à la fin
l'objectif pour le quinquagénaire ce
classé en milieu de tableau mais surtout
prendre du plaisir qu'importe le
résultat le soutien et la fierté du
coach reste indéfectible c'est un
bosseur c'est quelqu'un qui a pas peur
d'affronter
la dureté des entraînements en sachant
que bon je suis pas le plus facile sur
ce sujet c'est quelqu'un qui est très
allé sur les longues distances et donc
là voilà je pense que le le 100 m c'est
vraiment un beau challenge pour lui le
sportif s'envolera bientôt avec sa
famille pour le Japon rendez-vous le 6
août pour l'épreuve de 100 mètres nage
libre